cómo
por favor
[Aplausos]
qué tal buenas tardes soy muy emocionada
no había visto lesionar y todo está muy
emocionante todo
pues bueno buenas tardes como buenos hoy
hasta riveros ya no soy periodista este
pero
[Música]
trabajo en la fundación lego que somos
parte del grupo lego pero en realidad
somos una entidad aparte entonces no
somos la parte de responsabilidad social
corporativa
y no quería venir aquí a hablarles
específicamente de nuestra misión y lo
que hacemos aunque sí voy a hablar de en
qué creemos porque creemos que es
importante
y creo que la mejor manera era
precisamente con esta pregunta nosotros
nos dedicamos en temas de aprendizaje a
través del juego y yo lo que hoy quiero
hacer es platicarles de por qué el
aprendizaje a través del juego es tan
importante para méxico y porque lo
necesitamos yo creo que muchos aquí
hemos escuchado que hay una crisis
educativa a nivel mundial no de
aprendizaje
y yo y en la fundación legos y creemos
que la manera de resolver eso es a
través del juego y eso es algo
incluso hasta radical pero no porque
nadie toma en serio el juego porque no
podemos imaginarnos que un problema tan
complejo y tan grande a nivel mundial se
pueda resolver con algo como pues un
tema que nadie toma en verdad en serio
que es uno de los retos que este que
enfrentamos que el juego es algo que se
hace cuando hay tiempo libre no es algo
que se hace cuando ya dejaste hacer lo
importante
pero aparte de que si quiero enfatizar
que puede ayudarnos a resolver el
problema educativo también en méxico nos
puede ayudar a resolver problemas más
clave como la falta
los problemas laborales que enfrentamos
y yo sé que muchos aquí pronto van a
estar
pues empezando su carrera laboral y de
ahí también de productividad y
creatividad que tenemos en el país pero
antes de empezar para qué
no nos vayamos directo al tema ya los
problemas quiero hacer una actividad de
juego entonces con lo que tengan en su
en su persona con lo que sea les voy a
dar 40 segundos para construir un pad
ahorita vamos a empezar porque el pato
ese es el pato fue el el primer juguete
que creó nuestro fundador
ese es muy especial para nosotros pero
entonces ahorita en 10 segundos vamos a
comenzar con lo que tengan en la mano
van a construir un pato les voy a dar 40
segundos y luego van a mostrar cuando
acaben entonces empezamos
ok nos quedan 10 segundos
ya estoy viendo varias respuestas muy
creativas por aquí
ok ya pasaron 40 segundos pueden
levantar el pato que hayan creado aquí
allí con ropa con papeles parecen o con
una bolsa en el celular
muchos dibujan en el celular me parece
eso muy bueno
si voltean a ver hay un montón de
ejemplos está muy bueno este papel con
las manos acá atrás exactamente aquí vi
a alguien haciendo el sonido no entonces
usamos un montón de mecanismos no lentes
por aquella vía
basura o papeles es que es una bolsita
dibujado en el celular entonces pues esa
es una actividad muy rápida en realidad
pero parte de lo que quería del punto de
esa actividad
es reflexionar en qué pasó en estos 40
segundos lo que estuvimos viendo fue
flexibilidad mental porque obviamente no
tienen las herramientas a la mano para
hacer un pato entonces tuvieron que
adaptarse a lo que tienen memoria a
corto plazo porque se tienen que acordar
de los que les acabo de pedir imagen
mental tuvieron que acordarse de cómo
ser un pato para después poderlo plasmar
con cualquier este con lo que tuvieran
en mano funciones sociales muchos
voltearon a ver qué estaban haciendo los
demás este para no quedar mal o para
inspirarse regulación emocional no no
ponerse a llorar si no se les ocurre
como no hace cómo hacer el pato no
búsqueda visual precisamente buscando
esa inspiración entre otros etcétera
está nada más es una actividad de 40
segundos y el aprendizaje a través del
juego es mucho más complejo que
solamente poner a los niños a jugar pero
es un muy buen ejemplo para que veamos
cómo en un corto plazo puedes empezar a
hacer todas
a trabajar todos este tipo de éste
cualidades
pero bueno ya después de la parte
divertida quiero pasar a uno de los
problemas que me van a ayudar como
enfatizar porque es importante el juego
y no me quiere ir solamente a educación
pero por ejemplo ese lo sabemos mucho
que el 75% de las pymes en méxico van a
cerrar durante sus primeros dos años
aunque son representan más del 90 por
ciento de las compañías del país y
también nosotros aunque somos la 14a
número quince economía mundial tenemos
en el índice de innovación global el
número 56
aquí hay fondos aquí hay ahí tenemos una
población bastante grande tenemos todo
para innovación pero no lo estamos
logrando de la manera que al menos
nuestra economía nos podría dar la
oportunidad y muchos de ustedes que son
estudiantes universitarios y de ahí se
van a pasar ya
maravilloso mundo laboral van a llegar
ahorita a este
pues a un mercado con muchos retos y
también en una transición donde ahora en
realidad ya no estamos buscando gente
por lo que aprendió o por lo que conoce
sino por cómo lo usa y eso es un cambio
muy grande los niños que están leyendo
ahorita la escuela los trabajos a los
que van a entrar probablemente todavía
no existen y tenemos que hacer un
sistema educativo que esté que pueda
resolver eso no que que cree sus niños
que puedan tener las habilidades para
llegar a esos trabajos que ahorita no
podemos definir que son aquí esta
infografía habla de que tenemos cambios
tecnológicos sociales ambientales que
del día al día nos están haciendo
adaptarnos en la manera en la que
trabajamos en la manera que nos
organizamos etcétera
y con todos estos cambios quería ser
otro análisis esta es una foto que saqué
de una escuela en 1920 esto en méxico
estas en 1940
de ahí busque otra
muy conocida de los setentas 80s
otra conocida
según yo estás de las américas yo sé que
hay otro carrusel antes pero pero me
tocó estar y no sabía que hay un
carrusel nuevo ahí está el moderno y si
ven lo único que ha cambiado es que hay
colores dinámicos y es más divertida
el salón nada más porque hay colores
pero desde los 20 hasta acá no ha habido
cambios en cómo enseñamos en cómo cómo
es la estructura de nuestras escuelas
cómo transmitimos conocimiento
y para también
un poco irónico tomé carros de las
mismas décadas ahí están los 20 ahí
están los 50 ahí están los 70 y los 80
con un de lorean ya empezamos a innovar
con el tipo de puertas y ahora un tesla
entonces si piensan en cómo hemos
evolucionado y cómo hemos mejorado este
modo de transporte en específico es
increíble que a nivel mundial no ha
cambiado como tratamos la educación
y aparte esa foto de los 20
prácticamente nos podemos ir cien años
atrás y es lo mismo entonces
a eso nos dedicamos nosotros lo que
queremos es redefinir el juego y re
imaginar el aprendizaje y una de las
cosas claves no venimos aquí a decir ya
no enseñan matemáticas ni literatura
porque no no nos vamos a meter a temas
curriculares pero lo que sí es que no
podemos solamente transmitir
conocimiento
el conocimiento es muy importante pero
como utilizas ese conocimiento es lo que
va a ser clave para el futuro laboral el
futuro de los niños y niñas y el futuro
de ustedes también está en su propia
próxima etapa
eso es a lo que nos referimos con las
competencias del siglo 21 o habilidades
del siglo 21 que trata mucho de maneras
de trabajar maneras de vivir el mundo de
pensar y por ejemplo a qué se refiere
pensamiento crítico que efectivamente
queremos gente que sea crítica pero en
las aulas o en el salón de clases no
queremos que respondan no no no le
contestas a la maestra no seas
subversivo como trabajar en equipo puede
ser muy fregón y saber un montón de
cosas y sacarte puro 10 pero de aquí en
adelante en el trabajo si no sabes
coordinar un grupo si no sabes cómo
tener una buena habilidad emocional para
resolver conflictos
esos son las habilidades que ahorita
cualquier trabajo necesita
y de ahí hay más creatividad no como
enseñamos la creatividad no se enseña
sin pública y aparte no es algo con lo
que nacemos es algo que sí se puede
aprender y se puede desarrollar entonces
nosotros el juego creemos que es la
mejor manera para desarrollar estas
habilidades
si tenemos características
específicas
nosotros decimos que el juego el
aprendizaje a través del juego en el
juego debe de ser significativo
interactivo alegre debe involucrar
socialmente e involucrar activamente y
ser socialmente interactivo y antes de
irme un poco a hablar de las
características también hay otra cosa
muy importante que decir el juego es un
mecanismo evolutivo todos los animales
juegan y porque existe la evolución no
prioriza habilidades no prioriza
características que no nos sirvan para
la supervivencia pero porque juegan los
animales por ejemplo porque el juego te
da este este balance entre riesgo y
seguridad para aprender lo que te va a
ser exitoso en tu vida por ejemplo
simios es juegan mucho para enseñarle a
los pequeños en cómo saltar del árbol
hará algo como
cuando pelean entre ellos están
trabajando habilidades físicas
en donde más vemos juego hay uno muy
interesante de ratas unos científicos se
pararon un grupo de ratas que si jugaban
y otro que no les permitieron jugar
cuando las vuelven a juntar les ponen
aroma a gato y entonces todas muy
inteligentemente van y se esconden
porque asumen que va haber un gato por
ahí lo interesante fue que después
cuando ya el olor se había ido las que
jugaron salieron a explorar a ver qué
pasaba y las que nunca habían jugado no
volvieron a salir y se murieron de
hambre porque porque nunca tuvieron esa
habilidad de explorar de arriesgarse en
un ambiente seguro de medir sus fuerzas
y medir sus habilidades y eso pasa en
todos los animales desde hormigas ratas
que tienen un cerebro muy similar a
nosotros este etcétera no todo el mundo
hemos visto bastante fotos
en vídeos en discovery de animales
jugando entonces ya más en el contexto
mexicano debe de ser significativo
porque en realidad no nos preocupamos
mucho de que lo que estemos enseñando
tenga sentido para cómo lo vas a aplicar
en la vida puse el ejemplo de la niña
que ganó el premio de ciencia nuclear
porque creó un calentador de agua con
paneles solares ellas de los altos de
chiapas donde necesitaban una solución
de bajo costo y entonces hoy ella obtuvo
mucho apoyo de su familia y escuela para
crear algo significativo para ello
para ella las lecciones se vuelven más
interesantes cuando sabes para qué te
sirve y cómo lo vas a aplicar debe de
ser alegre tenemos que estar disfrutando
lo que estamos haciendo no puse picto
line porque aparte es muy buen ejemplo
de que ellos se nota que disfrutan mucho
poner estos temas complejos en una
manera más creativa y fácil de digerir
pero también precisamente afecta en
nuestro ambiente laboral nosotros
sabemos que aquí mucha un gran
porcentaje de mexicanas y mexicanos van
al trabajo y no lo están disfrutando
son nada más estamos viviendo para irnos
el fin de semana y así empezamos desde
la escuela desde la escuela es algo que
tienes que hacer no es algo que estás
disfrutando y cuando los disfrutas pues
empujarán tanto tus capacidades tu
manera de ver el mundo como del toro que
bueno esa me gustó mucho de cómo habla
como su creatividad e imaginación por
los monstruos lo lleva ahorita a donde
está
de ahí un involucramiento activo ya
tenemos muchos niños y niñas activistas
que están preocupadas por el cambio
climático pero debes querer estar
haciendo lo que estás haciendo para
tener un aprendizaje profundo no puedes
llegar como burócrata sentarte 8 horas a
copiar planas y después nos preguntamos
por qué las niñas y niños ya no ponen
atención no ya son burros porque se
distraen enseguida y son interactivos
pero los tenemos como un burócrata
sentado copiando planas con un receso de
20 minutos preparando los precisamente
para cuando ya se vayan el trabajo te
tienes que sentar a aplacar comes y
regresas no
de ahí se me está yendo el tiempo
interactivo eso es muy importante no nos
gusta fracasar y no nos gusta ver que
los niños para que hacen antes de
permitir los que hagan un error los vas
a ir a corregir no no no así no seas
no te estás equivocando y empezamos a
crear esta cultura de que ya no nos
gusta fracasar y por lo tanto no vamos a
explorar y nuestra creatividad va a
bajar y que no se arriesga no crea no
crean nada nuevo y eso es muy clave esta
gráfica lo que mencioné es como las
grandes mentes del mundo siguen creando
hasta el final de su vida
después socialmente interactivo
prácticamente es lo tenemos que hacer en
grupo lo tenemos que hacer con gente de
nuestra edad aquí puse a los niños
triquis porque ahí dicen comparten un
sueño de jugar en la nba ellos mismos se
están alimentando la inspiración y las
ganas de seguir practicando porque están
en un grupo y por ejemplo aquí todo es
muy individualizado no vayas a copiar
sites y copias se reprueba en vez de
enfocarnos en qué aprendizaje hay cuando
el niño le explica a otra niña por qué
por qué son las cosas de esa manera
ahí estás fortaleciendo el que explica y
el que escucha porque se lo van a
explicar de otra manera que a lo mejor
la maestra no luego pues no tiene la
capacidad por no tener la edad no
y en general esas son las cinco
características del tiempo se fue más
rápido de lo que pensé pero por ejemplo
es a mí me parece muy importante porque
hay un estudio que se hizo en jamaica
que se buscó
hubo se vio los resultados 20 años
después de un grupo de niños y niñas en
estado de vulnerabilidad que tuvieron un
programa con juego y otro sin juego y
los que tuvieron juego aumentó la
graduación de educación media por 44%
también de literatura por 17 pero lo más
importante es que a nivel económico
lograron tener el mismo nivel económico
que los niños y niñas de una clase media
o alta entonces el juego efectivamente
también puede ayudar a combatir la
inequidad si tuviera más tiempo les
cuento más pero muchas gracias ahí está
nuestra página web para más información
y mi correo electrónico
[Aplausos]